foreign
foreign
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
David Pac-Man show he's got
the content don't you know search a
subject but don't forget to add his name
at the end of the subject
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about his Gardens pretty good Garden
here
you should also know
that there is a bonus show
producer power will give his take which
is a pretty decent perspective Pat knows
what he's talking about
if you're thinking about joining the
David Pac-Man show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name at the end of the subject if
you're thinking about joining the David
Pac-Man show
it down look at that look look at that
look at that look at that look at that
that is
smarter than you what you think he's
smarter than you smarter
[Music]
look at that look at that look at that
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser ant-man's a loser
like that this is look at that Alex
Jones is lying to you that might come as
a Shopkin
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
a corporate takeover censorship
debanking arrest tyranny
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
Linda corporate takeover censorship
demanching arrest tyranny look at that
look at that
look at that look at that
[Music]
there's a story
[Music]
light light that did seem out of sight
now I take it where I go
bro every time I hear that theme song
ring it makes me wanna sing that catchy
thing it goes
[Music]
[Music]
from the river
are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know the guy who fits
that bill of aggressive with political
will but David pectin shows you your
political knowledge sign up for a
membership now for the bonus show that's
best in town who's the current president
of the United States
who's the current president
I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
time to pluck it
or remember
[Music]
all right wow thank you uh welcome
everybody we have whoa and wow I
literally just lost my mic again did
people see that oh God what a start uh
let's see if we can get what is
happening here don't worry everybody I I
have maybe I'll just hold it like this
the whole time
um I do have new equipment coming very
soon it's just it's a long story as to
why I'm even using this mic let's see if
I can get it all teed up here for us
hold on
that was very very dangerous
uh I should sue I don't know who okay
there we go
all right let's get everything set up
one and two dear God that was we almost
just we almost just lost the stream uh
in the metaphorical and proverbial sense
okay welcome everybody tonight we have a
debate between incumbent
the pillow was right about the machines
that's exactly right incumbent
Democratic Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer
and
Challenger from the Republican side
Tudor Dixon now I'm already bummed out
by the first Super Chat here David why
are you covering this and not the
Wisconsin Senate debate that's likely to
be more competitive I'm always doing
something wrong and I apologize for that
but this is the debate that we put on
our debate schedule before the Wisconsin
debate was even scheduled this is the
one we've been promoting and so
this is the debate that I'm airing I
hope that people will allow that
to take place okay thank you very very
much now
to Jack's point the good news is that so
far the data is pointing away from Tudor
okay
um Gretchen Whitmer is currently leading
by an avarage of 8.2
as much as 11 and it's as close as a tie
there's an American greatness poll I've
never heard of that that has it tied but
on average it is an eight point deficit
for Tudor
so
um that is the good news okay let's see
if we can get
um let's see if we can get our shot set
up I want a perfect shot for my audience
I would have nothing less uh there we go
and then we want to make sure we go up
here that's good
then there
and then let's tighten that up
okay and then we'll put that right in
the corner
and uh that looks good okay
no audio right now but we'll keep the
audio up and this will be starting very
very soon okay
um couple different things here to talk
about I don't know how many of you heard
about this but Alex Jones has been hit
with a billion dollar verdict for the
latest defamation case I have not yet
heard whether he has changed his mind on
that sweet sweet bonus show money but
reportedly he will and
um it's an incredible thing now I want
to make sure people understand
I don't take pleasure
in the imminent destruction of Alex
Jones entire media Empire because I just
like seeing people suffer
I take my platform seriously
and I would expect that if I abuse the
platform there would be consequences
proportionate to the level of abuse the
level of abuse that was Alex Jones
I I I don't even know whether to call it
coverage of the Sandy Hook trial
is such a misuse of the platform that
it's appropriate that the consequences
are serious now I'm not saying Alex
Jones should never be allowed to work
again if he wants to get a job you know
at a gym advising people on supplements
and you know stay hard and whatever it
is they sell
if some good I mean I'm not saying the
guy should starve to death right
I'm just saying there should be
consequences proportional
to what he did and the lives that he
ruined
and um let's just leave it at that Blake
London says we appreciate you streaming
your coverage keeps me sane thanks for
all you do very much appreciate that
thank you very much I do have a new
element on my audio now many of you of
course are familiar with the following
Mike pillow Clips we're doing a classic
as well as
over 54 countries have now been taken by
the machines I also now have a similar
clip from my own conversation with
pillow I didn't
sarcasm wait there you go that's pillow
talking to me and by the way if you did
miss that interview it was very much
worth watching let me ask because we're
getting to the end of our time and we
have a lot of other things to talk about
a couple just quick things that came
from the audience when you talk about
the way this was a question for all of
you when I met the audience I meant you
guys machines I just want to clarify you
mean electronic voting machines and
those because people write to me and
they say I'm worried Mike pillow is
gonna come after my espresso machine my
lathe my all these other type I'm sure
I'm sure they do David now you're just
being sarcastic and the little left-wing
humor
that could be your headline Mike Lindell
wants to get rid of the machine I will
tell you this yeah we're in an apex in
history okay where the technology we
have out there like in in
um
Australia where they use drones to come
down and tell you to go back by the way
tons of Australians emailed me after and
told me this isn't true back in your
house the stuff is going on there where
we have been robots and every
if you look
you look everything that can be hacked
you got you know credit cards companies
get hacked businesses get hacked yes um
uh Gaslight or gas we have gas companies
get hacked all these things are hacked
when they get hacked you have it all
involves money or insurance so you have
you know the good Geeks and they patch
it up who did this attack who did this
Cyber attack who broke into this is on
YouTube over 300 000 views yeah my
computer and they fix it and they put up
better protection virus protection but
when it happens in an election you can
lose your country that's all I'm about I
don't know I just wanted to clarify that
that's all that if you if you're gonna
take an election which China was
involved in this I'll say it straight
out you just seen where the guy the code
check or whatever it was a call check I
believe in Michigan just got indicted
arrested and uh for China to be involved
in the 2020 election that went out like
that actually went out in the news just
a week ago okay I'm telling you that
with with with computers we just did the
preliminary injunction down in Arizona
that judge said why why um the hand
county is vulnerable he's just all over
the place you know it's it's impossible
to even keep up with it all well too and
here's what my attorney said he said you
know what when you have a computer you
can you can change one number you can do
anything you hack in and you can do it
can affect Millions where if you had to
do the same thing with paper
um you would have to have a whole cabal
of people you would have to have
thousands and thousands of people okay
instead of having you know to be
protected our elections need to be
protected they do all of our elections
right down to the school boards you
can't have people breaking in and
hacking into computers that's not such a
thing and David doesn't it doesn't it
bother you that these guys have never
said hey we have nothing to hide show us
what's inside these computers instead
the attack Tina Peters who that image
it's it's just endless so anyway I would
definitely recommend then people check
out the full interview leave a comment
Etc kg says I guess it's a low bar but
it's easier to follow what fetterman is
saying than Mike pillow just saying it
is easier to follow fetterman yeah
Mike pillow will be the protagonist in
the next Terminator movie The Hero we
need in our war against machines well
said well said thanks to Jason sickmeyer
for kicking us off today gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com I do
truly appreciate that also thank you to
nug Wrangler now sir subscribed 37
months on Twitch I believe that's a
record also thanks to Sam the sleaze bag
for the twitch Prime subscription
putting us at three uh just a reminder I
am not trying to text with any of you
there are people in my audience getting
scammed by
impersonators on YouTube saying hey I'm
David want to chat with me on Whatsapp
I'm not trying to chat with any of you
on WhatsApp okay love you not trying to
chat with you on WhatsApp do not send
anyone money I'm not I'm not selling you
crypto I'm not buying crypto I'm not
texting I'm not whatsapping I'm not
providing any kind of Technical Support
I'm just hosting the show the only way
to talk to me is to call in when we take
phone calls okay do not fall for the
scams they are everywhere we're
reporting them as quickly as we can
good we got that out of the way now
I do have to talk to people about
something very ugly that is going on
right now and part of me thinks like I
should wait until there's more people on
the stream but I want to make sure I
have time for this okay
we have been permanently suspended from
tick tocks
okay I posted on my Twitter about it
we have now been permanently suspended
from Tick Tock for our content
misidentified as promoting covet and
election lies so understand
we would post on Tick Tock and go hey
here's some right-wing clown lying about
the election
here's the truth about the election
here's a right-wing clown lying about
kovids
here's the truth about kovitz
we have been banned because magats are
just Mass reporting our content and The
Tick Tock Auto moderation system is not
sophisticated enough to tell the
difference now I see people Billy Joe I
love you buddy but I've got to call you
out Billy Joe on Twitch is saying sorry
David I care zero about Tick Tock that's
great Billy Joe
we had over 200 000 followers on tick
tock
hugely in the 18 to 24 age bracket
there is no other platform right now
where people doing what we do
are reaching people that young I believe
it's important to reach people that
young okay you don't have to care about
Tick Tock Billy Joe
but the point is if we don't reach that
demographic Charlie Kirk is reaching
that demographic
and we had explosive growth so what can
you do to help
two things okay um by the way if you go
to ticktock.com davidpackman show now at
davidpackman show it's it's gone just
completely and totally gone
okay so here's the deal
the account Tick Tock support on Twitter
send them a message and say
David packman show
was banned erroneously
please reinstate David Pacman show this
is one thing you can do on Twitter if we
do Matt there's 3 000 people watching uh
this this stream right now
if even one out of 10 of you 300
messages go to tick tock support you can
Dev open DMS okay
I believe they will consider reinstating
us and secondly there's this article on
Business Insider
how to email Tick Tock when you have a
specific support question or issue okay
they list all these emails email every
do one email to every single one of them
okay and say David Pacman show was
erroneously suspended they are debunking
misinformation please put them back on
okay now I don't know that I would email
like the Korea one but but a lot of
these make a lot of you know uh Business
Services support creator Mark just dump
it in okay
I know a lot of you don't care about
tick tock
I have seen the power of this I go
around and people come up to me now with
tears in their eyes and they go I love
your Tick Tock it happened to me
yesterday at the grocery store I was
looking for a quinoa if you can believe
it and couscous both quinoa couscous
separate dishes
and a guy came up to me and said I love
your Tick Tock they don't know about the
podcast they don't know about anything
they go tick tock tick tock tick tock
tick tock okay so let's see if we can
get ourselves reinstated on there it
would be huge we were on our way to a
million followers on Tick Tock we
weren't even making money you don't even
make money on Tick Tock it's just to
reach the young people
I was making crudite with salsa and uh
ricotta and I was gonna dip asparagus
and Ricotta and call it crudite like a
completely clueless fool and then a guy
came up to me and said I love your Tick
Tock all right so
I'll report to you guys
um
what what goes on with that meanwhile I
want to say thanks to Jason sigmaier and
Gordon Hall for gifting two more
subscriptions at joinpakman.com and also
thanks to tr napsta for
um another twitch Prime subscription
which I very much appreciate and lastly
Amber Bridgeman Amber welcome for
whatever reason the ladies dominate
membership sign ups during live streams
our audience is 70 male during the live
streams the ladies dominate the
subscriptions okay the debate starts in
10 minutes we are monitoring a number of
different feeds I hope that this
actually works and goes live at 7 pm
Eastern
um okay let's get to some other things
because there are so many things to talk
about major news today and things I want
to get to before it is too late
um
oh okay yeah let's look at a couple
clips from the uh from the hearing today
we also interviewed Brad parscale yeah
president Trump's former campaign
manager
he told us he understood that President
Trump planned as early as July that he
would say he won the election even if he
lost right and just a few days before
the election Steve Bannon a former Trump
chief White House strategist and outside
adviser to president Trump spoke to a
group of his associates from China
and said this
and what Trump's going to do is just
declare Victory right he's going to
declare victory but that doesn't mean
he's a winner he's just going to save
the winner we know the Democrats more of
our people vote
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and Trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy he's
going to clear himself a winner so when
you wake up Wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestone right
also if Trump is if Trump is losing
by 10 11 o'clock at night it's going to
be even crazier we know no because he's
going to sit right there and said they
stole them I'm directing the Attorney
General to shut down all ballot places
in all 50 states it's gonna be no he's
not going out easier if Biden's winning
Trump is going to do some crazy [ __ ]
as you know Mr Bannon refused to testify
in our investigation he's been convicted
I just dropped my stream deck where I
was trying to configure some new drops
for you guys predicted of criminal
contempt of congress and he's awaiting
sentencing but the evidence indicates
that Mr Bannon had Advanced knowledge of
Mr Trump's intent to clear Victory
falsely on Election night but also that
Mr Bannon knew about Mr Trump's planning
for January 6th he certainly seemed to
here's what Bannon said on January 5th
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow it's all converging and now
we're on as they say the point of attack
right the point of attack tomorrow
I'll tell you this
it's not going to happen like you think
it's going to happen okay it's going to
be quite extraordinarily different and
all I can say is strap in yeah and
people ended up dying you have made this
happen and tomorrow it's game day so
strap in let's get ready yep not
particularly uh auspicious Beginnings
for what was a massive historical
disaster thanks to graveborn who just
gifted 50 subscriptions on YouTube look
at that also a super chat from Daniel
should have asked Mike pillow to predict
when your Tick Tock would be reinstated
no such process to decertify a tick tock
band very much well said
also thanks to Rory Karen Duff Rory
karenduff who is new member number 58
today let's continue with some of these
clips uh Trump continuing to lie why
didn't crazy oh hold on that's not good
why didn't crazy Nancy Pelosi call out
the troops before January 6 which I
strongly recommended that she do she
actually did we now have the evidence of
it Trump did not actually request
Security on January 6th that has been
widely widely debunked let's look at a
couple other Clips before the debate
starts this is going to be a very very
interesting debate
uh
uh let me see what else we did the um
we did the Rogan stuff already
um oh this isn't oh this is interesting
footage yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Senator Schumer is at a secure
location
and they're locked down in the Senate
there has to be somewhere we can
maintain the sense that people have
that there's some security or some
confidence
that government I'm not a Pelosi fan but
this footage of her commitment to
finishing the process and not allowing
these lunatics to get even a temporary
Victory I respect it
I saw Karen elect the president of the
United States
did we go back into session
did go back into session but now
apparently everybody on the floor is
putting onto your desk masks to prepare
for breach
I'm trying to get more information
they're putting on their tear gas masks
all right so you guys get the point uh
seven minute video that I absolutely
um
encourage you to check out NH Barracks
says play Arkansas
arcanza I forget how Trump said it sock
draw blowns someone sent me you guys
want to check this out someone sent me a
blowns I think Trump the other day meant
to say blood and bones and he said
blowns and Travis sent me a song I want
to use it but the audio quality isn't
very good but I'll play a little bit for
you here
is that original
for his wife
stealing documents and sound them for a
price
taken democracy and stabbing it with a
knife and
and deepest soul that somehow makes me
feel so nice
okay anyway so I said if you can like
put together
you know I don't want to say like a
better produced version I just mean like
a little bit better audio quality with a
separate mic it's it's funny I think I
think it would be good uh okay couple
other things here from the standpoint of
media
um let me see what I had
on my list
um
oh they're doing the stroke stroke uh
sort of like making fun of a stroke with
John fetterman we covered that on the
podcast today I hope you've all checked
that out
uh conspiracy stuff
um oh yeah Jesse Waters just seems very
deranged now check like I mean now he
has for a while but check this out I am
impressed with the Democrats and I don't
always say that but they are so devious
so deceptive they plot they plan they
deceive they knew this print was gonna
print hot today on inflation and they
timed this perfectly because the stock
market up like 800. this is gonna
probably blow out the interview you
really gotta hide the fact that the
stock market was up 800 points
on the nightly news channels
maybe a one
here it takes a little bit out of the
number that dropped and I sometimes wish
that the Republicans could be as crafty
as this they were pretty crafty with the
migrant flights to the vineyard but they
have to counter punch huge
the bottom line is that everyone's
losing money under Joe Biden they're
losing it from their paychecks they're
losing it from the stock market people
are losing their lives we're losing our
border uh little kids are losing their
gender because they've lost it in fact
it was actually just in those Cubbies
where kids put their stuff that's where
they left their gender man this guy is
Bonkers really really really Bonkers
crafty it's crafty
uh okay yeah
Let's uh look at just a couple of let's
listen to a couple of voicemails as we
wait here for the start of the debate
just two minutes from now what is the
coupon code today the coupon code is
right up there it's big voting 22.
big voting 22.
big voting 22. hey guys I just we just
got a message from Tick Tock support
saying your account will remain banned
thanks for reaching out after further
review your account will remain
permanently banned
to appeal submit an inticket in-app
ticket
but we can't do that because we're
banned we literally don't have access to
the app all right boy uh the protocol I
mentioned earlier we've got to continue
okay so step number one send a message
to tick tock support on Twitter
Tick Tock support on Twitter and say the
David packman show was erroneously
banned
and then on this page
um Business Insider has a page called
how to email Tick Tock when you have a
specific support question or issue it
lists like 10 different emails email
every single one it really can make a
difference okay and by Monday I'll have
a little more info for everybody all
right let's listen to a couple of
voicemails before the start of this
debate
uh let's see what else we have as far as
that goes David it's a beautiful day
today gonna have a beautiful stream
uh but it's not a normal stream
this one's an intervention we need to
talk about the sweater vests
stop lying to yourself stop lying to us
you have a child now to think of and you
sir have a problem we only say it
because we love it because we love you
put that sweater vest down hmm yeah I
mean it's a joke related to oan host
Allison Steinberg making fun of sweater
vests which I don't wear I don't think
I've ever worn a sweater vest on the
show
[Music]
um
okay let's see what else we have here
so just
because they think is attractive now is
probably not going to be attractive I
mean that's true I mean Beauty Norms
change Whitney's right about that think
about
the 80s or you know the 1600s all of
like those trending things the facial
features of like you know this and that
or whatever like those things fade
because it's like it starts to get stank
on it people start to spin things start
to go bad like oh well all right well I
mean not a not completely deranged
message from uh Whitney by the way
should I have a backup stream ready to
go in case this one doesn't work
I mean a stream called wood
I don't know it's I hope that this works
but I'm just not sure because I can tell
on the Detroit Free Press you voiced
your concerns my name is Brian Spencer
all right good the debate is starting
this is Tudor Dixon versus Gretchen
Whitmer and
um the counter will continue if we get
to 100 then tomorrow night we will have
the Rafael Warnock Herschel Walker
stream which I think will be very
exciting and interesting and scary and
dystopian and all of those different
things the incumbent here is Gretchen
Whitmer Democratic governor of Michigan
the Challenger is Tudor Dixon she is
Maga endorsed and Trump endorsed and as
of right now this moment Whitmer leads
by about eight points in recent polling
this is their first ever televised bait
which is a very very exciting thing
sinsu says I don't do Tick Tock but I
can still email their support to get you
reinstated love you thank you since you
very much appreciate it here we go
tonight live from Grand Rapids and being
seen and heard on our partner radio and
television stations and on the web the
two major party candidates for governor
democrat Gretchen Whitmer and Republican
Tudor Dixon will debate the issues that
viewers from across the state told us
that they were interested in quickly
Obama has very basic rules each
candidate will have 60 seconds to answer
each question an automatic 30-second
rebuttal will be available following the
Canada's first response after that we
move on to the next question for the
next hour the candidates campaign's
purpose participated in a virtual
drawing recently that has Governor
Gretchen Whitmer giving the first 90
second opening statement Governor thank
you for being here and pleased again
great thank you Rick and thank you Wood
TV for hosting us you know I grew up in
this community about 10 miles from here
right I grew up in a household that was
bipartisan and we had very different
perspectives but we shared values and
that's how I know when we stay focused
on what really matters it's a lot easier
to see we all want the same things Great
Schools good jobs safe roads and
communities as Governor I've sired over
900 bills every one of them bipartisan I
will work with anyone who's serious
about solving problems and that's how we
made the biggest investment in State
history in public education is how we
put 170 000 michiganders on paths to
higher education and skills tuition free
it's how we secure the future of the
Auto industry is built here in Michigan
we also paid down 14 billion dollars of
State debt amassed a record rainy day
fund and not only did we not raise taxes
we cut taxes for small business well I
think tonight you're going to hear a lot
of divisive rhetoric and a focus on the
past for my opponent here's what
separates us I still believe there is
more that unites us than divides us I
believe in our democracy I believe in
decency and that's what I'm going to
focus on tonight and every minute I'm
governor of this great state let's work
together and build a better future for
our kids
Mrs Dixon welcome to the debate thank
you for being here your 92nd opening
statement please
good evening Michigan I'm excited to be
here because for many of you it's the
first time you're hearing from me
directly I want to tell you a little bit
about myself I'm a mom I'm a wife I'm a
cancer survivor and I'm a worker I used
to work many hours on the shop floor of
a steel foundry and I've owned a small
business that was crushed by lockdowns
in the state like many of you I also
know what it is to have my children
locked out of school and then have to
try to get them back on track I know how
important it is to have safe communities
so that we don't have to worry about our
kids going out to play outside and I'm
running for governor because quite
frankly Gretchen Whitmer has let us down
the last four years have been
disappointing at best
everything is more expensive our
community communities are less safe our
job creators struggle to create jobs and
many are saying they think the American
dream in the state of Michigan is dead
our schools are getting worse and our
roads haven't been fixed
I'm sure you remember the promises that
this Governor made four years ago right
here on the stage she's going to try to
attack me tonight to distract from her
broken promises her record of broken
promises but I'm going to focus on the
future I'm going to talk about how to
make Michigan Freer and more prosperous
oh boy we're going to forge a
family-friendly future
Canada dispo thank you very much I want
to move on to the first question and it
is it is sensitive it's deeply personal
and it's very topical and it's not
surprising that one of the most often
question asked for our viewers was about
abortion each one of those questions
came with a point of view it came with
what people were feeling and sometimes
it was agonizing to read some of those
questions but what I wanted to do truly
do is I want to get to where you are on
this issue very clearly Ron from
Allendale did a really good job he asked
pretty simply when he said please
clearly explain your views on abortion
they have to help Ron get to that answer
I'm going to ask you and I will hold you
to this if I can if you support abortion
rights I want you to tell me what if any
limitations you would accept if you
oppose abortion rights I want you to
tell me what if any exceptions you would
allow
what merch your first question for 60
seconds this is an important question
when the Supreme Court overruled Roe v
Wade it took away rights that we've had
for 49 years right so I've had my whole
life are now been ripped away from women
and girls in this country Michigan could
revert to a 1931 law that makes it a
felony no exceptions for rape or incest
criminalizing doctors and nurses the
only reason that law is not in effect
right now is because of my lawsuit
stopping it when Roe fell Mrs Dixon
celebrated that she said it didn't even
go far enough she said she wanted to
make abortion a felony no exceptions for
rape I can already see where this is
going to go and throw doctors and nurses
in jail that is too extreme yeah people
in chat are yeah we know that just wait
for Dixon's explanation here in at risk
right now I am fighting to protect our
righteousness my lawsuit would have kept
the law as it is our legislature
wouldn't take action and so now we have
a ballot initiative
I will be voting yes Governor thank you
I hope in your rebuttal you will answer
that question about any limitations uh
Mrs Dixon I want to know if you oppose
abortion rights what exceptions would
you make yes in her first answer she's
already being dishonest this is
obviously going to be a theme for the
night I've never said that I wanted to
criminalize people I've never said I
wanted this to be a felony she just is
completely making the my position on
abortion is clear I am pro-life with
exceptions for life of the mother but I
understand that this is going to be
decided by the people of the state of
Michigan or by a judge as the governor's
already stated a judge has already ruled
in this case
please understand that the governor
doesn't have the choice to go around a
judge or a constitutional amendment she
will lie to you tonight and tell you
that the governor can do something about
a constitutional amendment but you need
to understand that it's very very
clearly written and you should
understand her position it's extremely
radical is abortion up to the moment of
birth she's already proven it with her
record of voting she voted no on a ban
on partial birth abortion that's how
radical Gretchen Whitmer is on abortion
and she'll continue lying to you now
Governor I'd like you for you to Define
your position on abortion Mrs Dixon is
either
woefully under-informed about the office
she's running for or she's lying to you
it's that simple a governor will
absolutely impact these rights in fact
the only right abortion is still
accessible in Michigan is because of my
action this is a candidate who said a 14
year old child raped by a family member
is a perfect example of why we shouldn't
have abortion rights I've been fighting
to maintain the law as it is that's what
I support Rick here's the fact of the
matter to protect our rights we cannot
trust Ms Dixon are there any limitations
governor
wrecked my lawsuit would have preserved
the status quo with the limitations that
are on the on the books right now the
legislature wouldn't enact it and that's
precisely why we are going to the ballot
now thank you your rebuttal Minister
she's clearly stated she has no
limitation she doesn't even want
parental consent that's what the
proposal that she's out there talking
about every single day says she's lying
about my position and I can see why
she's a little confused about a
constitutional amendment because this is
a governor who time and time again
thought she was above the constitution
of Michigan in fact the people had to go
to the Supreme Court to try to rip her
powers away even though she held on to
them like Grim death This is how she's
going to treat the people of Michigan it
is not how I will our second question
deals with part of the same issue and on
the ballot this year will be a proposal
proposal three that is dealing with
abortion rights now
this may or may not change the
conversation between the governor and
the legislature depending on what
happens but to the degree that you
support uh or oppose this initiative I
want to know and I want you to answer
Alexander's question uh and this comes
from Walker it'll go the first question
will go to you I would like to know if
both candidates agree to uphold the will
of the voters no matter if proposal
three poses or fails you've already
spoken to this uh to some degree Mrs
Dixon but in other words uh if you're
elected and proposal three has passed
will you do anything to try to change it
or to go around it or to somehow go
against that vote you're right Rick I've
been very clear on this and I've made
this statement multiple times I will
always respect the will of the voter I
don't believe that there are laws that
I'm above unlike the governor here who
said on multiple occasions if there's a
law out there that I don't agree with I
think I I should be able to go around it
and Dana nessel who has also decided to
go around laws I don't believe in that I
believe in our Constitution and I
believe in the people's right to decide
Governor if you're elected governor and
proposal 3 fails will you then look for
other legislative Solutions or will you
accept that as the will of the people
well I'll always accept the will of the
people Rick but here's the fact of the
matter I still have a lawsuit that's
pending in front of the Supreme Court
and so ultimately that too will have to
be decided
I think it's really ironic when Mrs
Dixon stands here and says that she will
accept the vote the will of the people
this is a candidate who still denies the
outcome of the 2020 election true this
is a candidate who will not pledge to
accept the outcome of the November 8th
election correct so for her to stand
here and say she will respect the the
will of the people when she has not even
embraced the outcome of a last election
or pledge to embrace the outcome of a
future election nicely that tells me we
cannot trust what she's saying these are
fundamental rights we cannot make any
assumption that a Dixon Administration
would fight to protect women's rights
women's access to health care and and
families who are trying to grow their
family through IVF is one additional
example correct a 30-second rebuttal and
plenty to talk about there yeah if we're
talking about protecting women then we
should go through a few of the vetoes
that the governor has had recently
vetoing safe housing for pregnant women
that's pretty tragic also vetoing any
fun grant funding for parents who just
want to was the safe housing for
pregnant women someplace where they talk
you out of abortions pregnancy centers
because she said they offered
information on adoption that's not
exactly family friendly so once again
the governor is being dishonest with you
she wants abortion to be your only
option
30 second rebuttal Governor that's
ridiculous like so much of what I think
we're going to hear tonight we know what
the law is we know what women demand and
women require in their reproductive
health care we also know what this
candidate for governor has said about
abortion rights about ripping rights
away from our future generations of
women and girls the most important
economic decision a woman will make in
her lifetime is whether and when to Bear
a child
this candidate for governor wants to rip
that away from her
candidates we're going to move on and
this is going to be the first of our
video questions as you know we ask our
viewers to submit questions and a few of
them we reached out to and asked them to
record the verbatim of what they asked
us and this first one it really struck
me because each of us have kids in
public schools or in college and Carson
from Grand Rapids has an important
question that I feel certain is shared
by many of us and many of his peers
listen
as a high school student school safety
is a top priority for me uh-oh what will
you do in order to keep our schools safe
and ensure protection to all Michigan
students oh boy here we go
there are so many pressures for kids in
school these days and I would expand
Cason's question to say this
Sherry from Troy wants to know
in addition to school safety
how do you support students
60 seconds sure Rick well we've made
historic investments in education that
includes wraparound supports for mental
health I've listened to parents and I
know school safety and mental health of
our students is Paramount I got to tell
you as a prosecutor I led the efforts to
get prepared for a new school year
active shooter drills with our police
officers as a mom I am furious I'm angry
that in this country and only in this
country the number one killer of
children is gun violence as Governor we
need to act
I support Secure Storage I support
background checks I support red flag
laws my opponent on the other hand does
not she's proposed more guns less
oversight and eliminating gun-free zones
she claimed not to even know what safe
storage was which is exactly what the
Oxford families have been lobbying for
that kind of out of touch governance
only makes our kids more at risk when
they're in our schools Mrs Dixon 60
seconds on keeping children safe in
schools and their mental health yeah in
2018 our state police released a safe
schools report that safe schools report
covered everything from hardening our
schools to making sure that the mental
health of our students was taken care of
and making sure we're seeing those flags
when we see a child that's in danger
the governor hasn't even come out and
talked about the fact that her own the
the Michigan Department of Ed has now
come out and said there are times when
we can hide a dangerous situation from
parents if a student wants to harm
themselves or someone else we should
hide it from the parents we've never
seen something like this before we're in
really scary times we need to trust our
experts when our state police come out
with a report like that we need to take
it very seriously the money that we've
received so far from the federal
government could have been used to
harden our schools over this summer but
nothing happened we really need to take
that money and focus on how to keep our
our kids safe inside of those buildings
30 seconds Governor Whitmer is a
rebuttal please the same month as the
Oxford school shooting where four
children were murdered eight were
injured and the community was terrorized
Tudor Dixon posted on her social media a
picture of her shooting a gun
with the caption that said gun control
means using both hands she is too
dangerous and too out of touch to be
trusted with protecting our kids she'll
put the Second Amendment before second
graders every time we cannot let that
happen well done Mrs Dixon you have 30
seconds Gretchen whitmers made it pretty
clear she wants to make sure she takes
away any protection you can have she
wouldn't allow protection even inside of
the school or we know that's the best
case scenario if we have someone that
can shoot down a shooter shoot down a
threat but she doesn't want anything
like that she wants to make sure your
kids are in a Sitting Duck Zone where
there can be no guns and there's no
protection against them the idea that
she thinks that any having any type of
weapon is too dangerous for the state of
Michigan she'll take all of your guns
away Mrs Dixon the next question goes to
you when we stay on the subject of
schools and this is rather broad because
again it's a subject that we got so many
questions about I couldn't get every
Nuance in there so I want you to talk
about your view of Education how School
should operate how you think that should
work but patriotic than that we know
that Michigan's public schools are
always an issue in a governor's race and
the same is true now I want you to tell
me within that discussion of your view
on schools
the specifics as Governor that you'll
work to ensure that the best possible
outcomes for all Stu students in public
schools are achieved not just in the
high achieving schools but in some
schools that we know are struggling
sure and in our schools right now we're
seeing that we have incredibly low
reading scores we've talked about this
for years but after the pandemic and
kids being out of school for almost two
years we've gone through a crisis and we
don't have an opportunity right now to
catch our kids back up Michigan is one
of the only states where the governor
didn't immediately Implement a tutoring
plan for our students we've talked about
25 hours for every child to make sure
they get back on track we need to get
our kids back to reading and back to the
basics right now in Michigan schools as
you're seeing on the news parents are
really concerned about what their kids
are being taught with this sex and
gender Theory and not teaching them to
read write and do math there it is we've
made it very clear we want parents
involved in the child's education and we
want to go back to the basics making
sure our kids know how to read write and
do math from kindergarten to third grade
they're learning to read from third
grade on they're reading to learn if
they're missing that crucial step we're
robbing them Governor let's hear what
you have to say about that and how we
make sure that all students have as
clearly as possible the same
opportunities in all of our Public
Schools absolutely I love this question
five generations in my family went to
Michigan public schools I went to Forest
Hill schools right down the road this is
personal for me I know that an education
is what levels the playing field and
creates opportunity for every person and
that's why I worked with the legislature
in a bipartisan Manner and we delivered
the biggest investment in public
education in Michigan history we closed
the gap between districts we ensured
that we've got wraparound supports
whether it comes to mental health
supports or tripling the number of
literacy coaches we're dropping class
size and luring great people to go into
teaching that is how we ensure that all
kids have a great education we are
making great strides there is certainly
more work to more good work to do we
want to be a top 10 State when it comes
to literacy individualized tutors but I
need you to know this the person
bankrolling Mrs Dixon's campaign is
Betsy DeVos why is that because they
want to take half a billion dollars out
of our Public Schools correct
you have 30 seconds to respond Mrs Dixon
she says she closed the Gap what she
really did was close the schools and
when we talk about making sure there is
no wrong path for any child you should
know that when Detroit public schools
kept their schools closed longer she was
silent when Flint Public Schools closed
their schools down again
Gretchen Whitmer was silent in fact in
the midst of the pandemic when the
legislature said they would give her
money for reading scholarships one of
her people came out and said smelled too
much like vouchers because they don't
want parents to have control she doesn't
want you to have an impact on your
child's education Governor 30 seconds
Betsy devos's voucher plan might help
Betsy the boss and it might help Twitter
Dixon too because her kids go to private
schools I don't have a problem with kids
going to private schools that's her
choice but the fact of the matter is is
that most kids don't have those options
and that's why we've got to improve the
education system across the state of
Michigan so that every child has a great
education a Governor's job isn't just I
think Whitmer has a slight Edge so far
but nothing that's going to like
dramatically move the polling is my
opinion at this point your subject that
was very high on the list as you will
understand and people wanted to know a
thousand questions so that's an
exaggeration about the state's response
to covid-19
and there's no way to go through all of
the questions so as we sat around trying
to think of a way that we could get to
that question and give it some depth
here's what we want to do instead of
going one by one through every grievance
or why did this happen or why didn't
this happen I want you to think back
given the advantage of two and a half
years of knowledge that we didn't have
in March of 2020 and given the advantage
of hindsight which is always
particularly good
I want to first ask you Governor looking
back if there is anything that you would
have done differently and Miss Dixon
when I get to you I want to ask you if
you had been Governor what would you
have done oh that's governor
kovid was incredibly hard on every
single one of us we know that this was a
brand new virus that we did know a lot
about we knew that our hospitals were
filling up and that people were dying we
were in Desperate search of masks and
ventilators there were refrigerated
trucks outside of some of our hospitals
to store people's bodies who didn't
survive covet it was a desperate time so
I talked to the experts I listened I
asked questions of our national Experts
of State experts I talked to my fellow
Governors Republicans and Democrats and
we helped one another as we made tough
decisions because lives were on the line
Studies have shown that our actions
saved thousands of lives
now 35 000 people in our state have died
from covet
they may not matter to some but they
matter to me every single one of them if
I could go back in time with the
knowledge we have now sure I would have
made some different decisions but we
were working in the middle of a crisis
and lives were on the line
Mrs Dixon given the information that we
had
two and a half years ago what do you
think you would have done differently if
you were governor while the governor
wants you to believe that she did listen
to The Experts but we have the letter
from the nursing home Association that
said whatever you do don't send covid
positive patients into nursing homes and
yet the governor did when Andrew Cuomo
even backed off of this Governor Whitmer
doubled down
she even tried to hide the final report
of the numbers of how many deaths we had
in fact she's tried to hide a lot from
this pandemic she tried to hide or she
did hide effectively why her Department
of Health and Human Services director
left in fact she even paid him off with
a secrecy agreement the same with
unemployment what a debacle to have
eight and a half billion dollars
fraudulently sent out now I've got
people bringing bills from the state up
to me begging me to forgive the
unemployment that she's trying to get
out back because she accidentally sent
eight and a half billion out and what
about our students and she kept locked
out of schools and wouldn't listen to
parents when they begged her to let them
play let them play she wouldn't even
listen
Governor you have 30 seconds
none of what my opponent just said is
true it just isn't here are the facts
while my life was being threatened for
making hard decisions to save lives
across our state Mrs Dixon was spreading
conspiracy theories Mrs Dixon was
downplaying masks saying that this would
go away without getting back soon she
said kids couldn't get coveted had she
been Governor during the pandemic
thousands more people would have died a
lot of those deaths would have been in
our nursing homes
30 seconds unfortunately for Gretchen
Whitmer everybody knows that I have been
vaccinated and she's completely
dishonest but she can't be honest
because she knows that her response was
so completely horrendous in fact she
closed restaurants down longer than any
other state and we lost 3 000
restaurants but we just got a report
today just got the report today Michigan
is having a slower comeback than any of
our surrounding states so not only did
she make bad choices when she closed us
down and refused to open our schools but
she hasn't figured out how to recover
candidates we move on and this is one of
the more unusual questions that I've
ever had because we've never been quite
here since I've been covering politics
in the state of Michigan
has rarely had more of a robust treasury
there has been more money that has come
through some of it is federal a lot of
it is State money there are billions of
dollars that are still unallocated even
after the largest budget ever and the
largest school aid fund ever so my
question is and it goes first to you Mrs
Dixon
what do you do with that money do you
save it do you spend it
give it back to taxpayers none of the
above what do you do with maybe six or
seven billion dollars
well certainly you know I want some of
it to go back into schools to harden our
schools and to make sure that our kids
are getting caught back up as we've
stated I stated earlier Michigan is one
of the only states that didn't Implement
a robust tutoring system after the
pandemic to get our students back on
track and the test scores show right now
our third graders just failed their
literacy exams nearly 60 percent across
the state and in Detroit 90 so when we
talk about making sure there's no wrong
path that hasn't happened in the state
of Michigan we have the funding to make
sure our public schools have the
resources that they need it's time for
us to use them to make sure our kids get
back on track and focus on the basics
get back to Reading Writing and math the
governor still has not made a comment
about the fact that parents are begging
for our schools to go back to the basics
and get our kids back on track
Governor let's talk about a few stats
Michigan's economic recovery is the
fastest in any we've seen in our history
we have one of the strongest economic
recovers in the country we know that we
are seeing small business growth that's
outpaced any year that we've seen in the
last 23 years we've made record
Investments when it comes to securing
the future of the Auto industry here
General Motors seven billion dollars
building batteries Ford stalantis it's
not just about Autos it's about the
future of manufacturing future of Life
Sciences perigo moved their headquarters
from Florida here to Grand Rapids Pfizer
expanded in Kalamazoo we're also
onshoring ship production to bring
Supply chains home from China to
Michigan KLA SK siltron Calumet
Electronics Hemlock semiconductor we are
building the future of the economy and
we're also training our Workforce so
that they can get into those good paying
jobs you can raise a family on 170 000
michiganders are signed up for our
opportunities tuition free to get yeah
that's a big thing I would love for them
to say who is the current president and
is he legitimate just be on
beyond that Michigan is
a rate in fact
for small businesses than any other
state except for New York were tied for
losing the most small businesses we've
also lost 82 000 jobs while Gretchen
Whitmer was in office and she hasn't
saved the automotive industry she's only
trying to save face now because she
knows Ford left and went to Kentucky and
Tennessee and when she was asked her
response was I think we didn't know
Governor that's ridiculous listen we
have top we are top 10 state for new
business we are the number one state in
the nation for clean energy job growth
we have put our fiscal house in order my
opponent is proposing a 12 billion
dollar cut to our our budget she likes
to say she has business in the steel
industry but in the time when that
industry had record profits her company
didn't pay the gas bill didn't pay the
trash bill didn't pay their employees
and got sued dozens of times by other
businesses they didn't pay either
let's stay with Michigan's budget to
some degree and it also talks on another
topic that was discussed a lot in this
studio four years ago and we'll go to
you Governor first with this there has
been more money put back into Michigan's
budget per Rhodes some of that came from
bonding you did early on some of it's
coming from the infrastructure package
but here's the problem
Michigan roads all roads but Michigan
roads always need to be fixed it's a
Perpetual type of thing and I thought
John from Muskegon came up with a great
question because he worries about this
he says with the current push towards
electric vehicles are the gas taxes
going to be raised even more to pay for
Road repairs since the EVS aren't paying
for gas tax my question is are we going
to need a new Revenue stream and maybe
even a new distribution formula for
funding roads going forward I'd be
shocked if either of has thought John
was brilliant he's making an observation
that is really smart and I appreciate
that you know we listened to people as I
got all across the state of Michigan
when I first ran for governor and we
know that when you've got to replace the
rims on your car it's money out of rent
or child care this is a fundamental for
Michigan families and so we've already
rebuilt 13 000 Lane miles 900 Bridges
there are orange cones and barrels all
over the state because we are fixing the
damros and moving dirt but you don't
overcome overcome Decades of
disinvestment in four years it is going
to be so Whitmer has no clue how to
actually answer the question as asked
let's see if Dixon does I predict no
later to get done will help us do more
when it comes to fix in our roads
rebuilding our bridges fixing water
infrastructure that brings water into
our homes the bite Administration sent
us billions with the infrastructure and
jobs act I'm grateful for that that will
help but as we think about the
transition that's happening in our Auto
industry our solution for roads is going
to have to transition as well Mrs Dixon
it's going to be a question the next
Governor is going to have to deal with
yeah I'm sure this question was asked
because four years ago on this stage the
governor was asked if she would raise
taxes to pay for the roads that she said
she was going to fix which we now know
her own roads commission says are in
worse shape than when she took office in
fact she said no she wasn't going to
raise the taxes that was ridiculous it
was nonsense you've heard those words
come out of it so she seems to not even
be going near the question remember that
when she was saying those words four
years ago then one of her first acts
when she got into office was to try to
raise your gas taxes by 45 cents in fact
when she says she's worked in a
bipartisan manner she's actually vetoed
Road funding in the past because she
didn't get her way on 45 gas tax you're
right we will have to figure out a way
to fund the roads it's going to take
public-private partnership in the future
but it's going to be a ways out because
the entire country is not going to go to
EV Vehicles overnight
Governor 30 seconds to respond I think
the evidence is all across the state
despite what Mrs Dixon's commercials say
we are fixing the dam roads we are
moving dirt we are using the right mix
and materials and they are built to last
but you don't overcome Decades of
disinvestment overnight we have
recognized that there is a lot of good
work to do when you see those orange
barrels see that as a sign of progress
and remember to please slow down they're
hard-working men and women on the side
of the road risking their lives to
rebuild infrastructure to power like you
know neither one of them has a clue
there's one idea which is tax electric
vehicles as if they were gas powered
there's another idea which explains how
once you reduce some of the negative
externalities of gasoline burning it
actually will generate more money it
will free up my yeah this stuff has been
studied and they're both they both have
no idea she's saying it'll take a second
term and maybe even several more terms
just to do what she promised in the
first place which she knew she couldn't
do but she wanted to earn your vote then
and now she's trying to get your vote
again
we learned Mrs Dixon I want to turn to
crime and policing I again was surprised
by the number of questions that we got
about this and I looked up a few
statistics and there are some that
support the idea this is uh from 20 2019
to 2021 uh the last year the numbers are
available and it comes from the incident
crime reporting from the Michigan State
Police and they show that there are some
violent crimes that are on the rise but
In fairness robbery rape and most
property crimes other than auto theft or
on decline however as Governor how can
you promote
us a reduction in crime and what is your
view on the question from a viewer in
Grand Rapids who says and by the way
this has been thrown around in this
campaign so I thought it was appropriate
knowing that there still continues to be
a defund the police movement out there
then what is your plan to rid our state
the framing of this question is
pathetic neither candidate wants to
defund the police almost nobody wants to
defund the police I mean come on
important question because we know the
governor came out and said that she
supports the spirit of defund the police
in fact we know that when we were all
locked down she went out and marched
with folks who held up signs that said
defund the police I'm actually endorsed
by the largest police Union in the state
the Michigan the Police Officers
Association of Michigan and more than
two dozen sheriffs including Democrats
because they are so upset about the fact
that the governor doesn't support them
my plan will put a billion new dollars
into policing to make sure they know
they're supported but also to recruit
and retain new police officers it's so
challenging to bring police officers to
a state where the chief executive
officer has supported defund the police
we're going to make sure that not only
are they supported but they have the
tools they need they have the technology
they need and they have the mental
health help they need and they will
always know that a Dixon Administration
has their back we will never defund the
police
my opponent is long on rhetoric and
short on facts and that's okay I gotta
tell you as a former prosecutor I have
sat with our law enforcement I have
worked Urban arm with them and that's
why the budgets that I have written have
been focused on supporting I can tell
you as Governor I've made too many phone
calls to grieving families who've lost
their loved ones on the front line
pretended too many funerals and
visitations and that's why we've got to
talk about gun violence my opponent's
proposing proposing policies that
increase guns decrease oversight and
eliminate gun-free zones that's not
going to make us any safer here's what
will I delivered a bipartisan investment
in our law enforcement a billion dollars
for training for recruiting for making
sure that we're Shoring up pensions for
those who risk their lives for all of us
every day every one of us deserves to
feel safe in our home and in our
communities investing in law enforcement
is what we have done and what we need to
continue to do to keep people safe
this is 30 seconds it must be so
embarrassing for the governor that it's
actually on tape that she said she
supports the spirit of defund the police
the spirit of it is to reform the police
right I mean like the the letter of it
is to defund the spirit of it is to to
reform and veto funding for our road
patrols now she's coming out and saying
she's bipartisan and she's supporting
the police but her record shows
something terribly different in fact
that's why we've lost a cop a day in
Detroit this year it's devastating to
see the chief executive officer treat
our police officers this way
governor I know Mrs Dixon is she is um
committed to her talking points but the
fact of the matter is just this week
with a group of Republican and
Democratic legislators I signed a bill
to support our secondary Road Patrol
just this week I was endorsed by a
different police organization and a
number of prosecutors and sheriffs
they're split you know why they usually
go to the Republican principle about
politics is
you could just genuinely like this story
she's telling she she literally sat down
with Republicans and Democrats and they
figured some stuff out
and it doesn't really matter because
your opponent can just lie and say you
didn't do it and you might lose because
the voters might not know any better
concerns about racial bias and law
enforcement and this is important
because we have seen so many cases
around the country uh that have been
really troubling and here's what he says
he says Rachel uh racial bias existed
law enforcement in policing charging
trials sentencing incarceration prisoner
abuse probation and parole if you would
please ask a question about Criminal
Justice System racial bias reform in
Michigan first governor do you agree
with that assessment why or why not and
if you agree what can you do about it I
think that we know there is always work
to do to make sure that people who are
policing communities are they are safe
they are supported but they are also
trained and that they are working with
the community that's something that's
really important I'm going to tell you
one of the most joyful things I've
attended over the last few years was an
expungement fair influent with the
sheriff and the prosecutor working with
our attorney general and Secretary of
State to help people who've already
served their time who simply want a job
and a fresh start to get back on that
effort that came about because of the
work that our lieutenant governor has
done with regard to improving our
Criminal Justice System there is more
work to do there is training we ask too
much of our Law Enforcement Officers we
need to support them with mental health
experts so that when they are in
communities everyone goes home at the
end of the day
Mr Dixon do you agree with the
assessment uh in that question and and
if you do what do you do about it we
need to always make sure that our police
officers have the training that they
need and the support that they need what
we're seeing in the state of Michigan is
many of the communities that used to
have police officers rise up out of them
and then they would become police
officers in their own Community which is
so important and so valuable to our
local communities they've stopped doing
that because of this rhetoric of defund
the police that you've heard across the
country because people have demonized
our police officers and made this a
career that people don't feel
comfortable in anymore in fact our own
Governor marching with the people who
are out there saying the police are bad
have helped move this narrative along
it's hard for our police officers and
it's hard for our community I think not
only do we need training in our police
departments but we also need to bring
ourselves figured out a great way to not
even weigh in on whether there is racial
bias around our police officers Governor
take 30 seconds and respond please
one of the important jobs of the
governor is to keep her cool and to be a
Healer in Chief
what Mrs Dixon is referring to was a
clergy-led moment of healing we had
police represented as well it was an
important Community moment what won't
heal the Divide is someone who makes a
rush to judgment like Mrs Dixon did on
the altercation and death of Patrick
leoya happened here in Grand Rapids that
won't fix problems we need to support
good cops we got to make sure
communities are safe we can and must do
both
Dixon as I've traveled around this state
I've had police officers tell me time
and time again too often Governor
Whitmer criminalizes the police and
glorifies the criminal she comes out on
the side of the person who's trying to
harm our cop she is someone who does
rush to judgment this is a real problem
when you have your police officers out
there in the line of duty in danger
every single day she's right I'm going
to support our police officers I always
have their back I will always make sure
that they know they are safe in this
state
this question will go right along with
what the two of you have already
addressed goes first to you Mrs Dixon
with 60 seconds where crimes are
committed with guns that involve guns
and the question arises how do you keep
guns out of the hands of people that
would do bad things with them okay given
the recent U.S Supreme Court ruling the
state's ability to make gun laws maybe
somewhat limited because of the Bruin
decision but no matter what
when you see Firearms related crimes
when you see gun violence what if
anything would you do to change
Michigan's existing gun laws or create
new ones again with the kind of Soul
about the Supreme Court 60 seconds one
of the biggest problems that we have in
the state of Michigan is that we're
letting people out too easily people
commit gun crimes and then they're back
out on the street this is a problem for
our police officers too they're afraid
to even arrest these guys for fear
they're just going to come back out and
Target them and we've seen that
happening police officers across the
state tell me that they are now being
ambushed as soon as they're out on the
job this is catastrophic we need to make
sure we are tough on crime in this state
this idea that you're going to take guns
away from law-abiding citizens and
somehow that's going to keep them out of
the hands of criminals that's never
going to work we have to make sure that
we are tough on crime when we find
someone who commits a gun crime they
need to be put away
this Administration is trying to hide
prison numbers from you they're saying
that the prisons are empty that we don't
have a crime problem our sheriffs across
the state have told me they're hiding
them in our jails and giving them lesser
violations and then letting them back
out on the streets that's catastrophic
governor
I'm a little confounded by what she just
said I I don't know that there's any
facts behind it I'll say this there are
so former prosecutor I take Public
Safety very seriously as a mom I'm
furious that in our country guns are the
number one killer of our children as a
governor I know we can and must act I
support Secure Storage I support
background checks I support red flag
laws this is how we keep our community
safer this is how we keep our kids safer
when they're in school my opponent
supports constitutional carry which
means more guns less oversight less
training she wants to eliminate gun-free
zones like at our schools
the work we have done has helped improve
safety there is more good work to do
without question but here's what we've
done with operation safe neighborhoods
we've got parole sweeps we're getting
illegal guns off the streets we're
working with local police departments
and we will continue to do so and take
any action we can to make our
communities safer Mrs Dixon 30 seconds I
don't think it can be any clearer the
governor's made her statement she wants
to take guns away from law-abiding
citizens she does not trust our
law-abiding citizens with their guns we
know this many of them can't be trusted
to do this on their own and she doesn't
even know that we're in a situation
where our jails are filled with violent
criminals that are beyond what our jails
can handle they're not they're not
putting them in our prisons she doesn't
even know what's happening in the
criminal justice system in her own state
Governor we're going to go to you but
I'm going to ask the control room to
there we go to reset that clock that was
distracting my apologies Governor at
least 30 seconds sure I mean I'd be
happy to give my 30 seconds to Mrs Dixon
if she wants to actually tell us what
kind of supports she might you know what
policy she might say to get guns off the
street to keep our communities safer I
still have it here that I don't think
that you've heard that and I think every
one of us deserves to know what is the
plan to get guns out of our communities
all right candidates we're coming down
to the end of this we have to move a
little quicker so I'm going to go with
you real quickly Governor let's talk a
bit about the economy we touched on it
earlier a little bit but one of the
questions we heard was like this and we
heard it a lot like this one from Paula
and Grace it's funny to say move more
quickly when the debate moderators
control the time and stuff we're going
to deal with the high inflation if
they're elected
Paula I appreciate the question but I
will stipulate that the governor doesn't
have the unilateral ability to change a
national or global economy but correct
there are some things you might be able
to talk about it Gene and Caledonia says
what's your position on removing the
taxes and retirement pensions this is a
very hot topic especially with the
inflation rate as high as it is she says
I'm considering moving out of Michigan
because of this and Charles from Hickory
Corners wants to know in light of people
hurting because of the economy will you
work to roll back the State's income tax
to 3.9 percent Governor start with that
or anything else that as Governor you
might be able to do there's a lot to
cover there so I'll start with this you
know we know that inflation is hurting
whether it's the price of gas or it is
the price of groceries a governor cannot
fix Global inflation but what we can do
is help keep more money in your pocket I
worked with the Republican legislature
to make sure that we leveled the
financial barrier to higher education
and skills so that people people can get
into good paying jobs 170 000 people are
in tuition free programs now we also
expanded tri-share which started here in
Grand Rapids by the way the state picks
up a third of the cost of day care that
parent a third of the cost and the
employer a third of the cost and for
people who are really struggling we have
expanded for 150 000 kids in Michigan
daycare that is free or low of cost we
also put our fiscal house in order
because of that because of the upgrade
in our credit rating and the money that
we've put in the rainy day fund we could
repeal the retirement packs which I do
support we could triple the Earned
Income Tax Credit which I also support
and a pause on the gas tax Mrs Dixon can
you tell me
what you think the governor could do
because obviously it's a big problem
yeah well it's very interesting that
they asked about the pension tax because
the governor stood here four years ago
and said that she would that that would
be one of the first things that she
would do would be repeal the pension tax
and that hasn't happened in the four
years that she's been governor in fact
the other question was would you try to
get the income tax down to 3.9 the
governor was actually offered two
different reductions in the personal
income tax to get money back in your
pockets but she vetoed both of those
it's not surprising this Governor has
vetoed more bills than any governor for
the past 70 years so I thought vetoing
bills was good for conservatives because
they don't want government doing too
much she vetoed that as well in fact
Michigan right now has some of the
highest gas tax in the nation we are we
have some of the highest gas prices in
the nation she hasn't come out and said
she's going to give you a gas tax
holiday now if she had done it before
you wouldn't be suffering so badly now
Gretchen Whitmer wants you to pay more
for gas to force you into electric
vehicles 30 seconds
by the way would that be so terrible I
mean
our gas prices in the United States are
not accurate in the sense that they are
subsidized and they don't reflect the
full environmental and social cost of a
gallon of gas that's why it costs more
in Europe they've cut your taxes but but
they know secretly none of it even goes
into effect until 2023 I don't play
those games I veto those games you
deserve honesty you deserve Solutions
you deserve leaders who can work
together and deliver for you and your
family that's what we've been doing
when we talk about inflation you should
ask the governor where she stands on
line five and your gas prices because
she has made it very clear that she
wants to shut down line five and will do
anything to do so even though Joe Biden
says no she's still trying to shut down
line five today line five would raise
the cost to heat your home it would
raise the price to fly out of our
Detroit airport in a time we need
Economic Development and it would raise
the cost of gas for your car but she
doesn't care about money in your pocket
she likes the political benefit
candidates we've come to the final
question in our debate we will have
enough time to complete it but I need
you to stay on time 2019 the legislature
passed the governor signed reform of
Auto no fault insurance it came with a
promise of lower premiums and choice in
the coverage that you had a 400 rebate
from the catastrophic claims Association
followed this spring one of the
consequences was a reduction in
attendant care that's for long-term
health care for people who have been
injured now this is going through the
courts it's going to go to the Supreme
Court but it cut those payments by about
45 dollars which had a real impact
obviously on families that depended on
those and Heather in Spring Lake wants
to ask this
I would like to know what each candidate
is going to do about fixing the auto
Reform Bill for the injured victims that
were injured before the auto reform my
son was injured in 2014 and has been
affected by the auto Reform Bill Mrs
Dixon's 60 seconds please well as you
said there is a lawsuit in the courts
right now and we're seeing that they're
saying that this was a contract that has
to be upheld and so that's very that is
very good news for the victims of this
situation but we probably need to talk
to the legislature to see if we can go
further there's always bills where
there's unintended consequences we're
losing a lot of our health care workers
because of this we have the opportunity
to work with the legislature to see if
there's something that we can do the
governor will tell you if only there was
some other system we could have for
Health Care wherein this wouldn't be a
problem giving you the bill you're going
to end up paying 48 dollars back for
every vehicle because this was too fast
she knew that these victims were looking
for compensation but she still gave this
out to try to buy your vote that's what
she's doing at the end of this election
Governor 60 seconds I'm sure my opponent
knows that the Republican Party controls
both chambers of our legislature we work
together because Michigan had high Auto
rates consumers wanted options and so
that legislation gave them options and
because of it they've been able to save
some money they got a rebate also we've
got more people who are driving who are
insured now because they can actually
afford some of the options
for people who were injured before that
law was signed they have a vested
interest and I believe that they deserve
the care that they need and so I am
eager to work with the legislature the
Republican leaders in the legislature
haven't come to the table yet but I'll
be a willing partner when they're ready
to do that
30 seconds
this Governor has proven time and time
again that she actually won't come to
the table she's she keeps claiming to be
bipartisan I want to remind you that she
has vetoed more bills than any governor
in the last 70 years which conservatives
claim to like her bipartisan willingness
to work with people do not be deceived
this is a woman who shut down the state
and had to have her powers her powers
removed by the Supreme Court do not
trust her with another four years to
terrorize you covered in 30 seconds
think that there are so many wonderful
things that are happening in Michigan
there are certainly some challenges
ahead I will continue to work with
anyone who wants to solve problems not
just score political points with
rhetoric but actually come to the table
with Alternatives I've heard a lot of
complaining and grievance tonight what I
haven't heard is alternative Solutions
that's what I'm always going to stay
focused on and I'll work with anyone who
brings that attitude and wants to solve
problems regardless of what side of the
aisle they come from
candidates we have come to the question
the question
for addressing those issues and
highlighting some differences between uh
the two candidates it's good for the
folks who are getting ready to vote
you've got 90 seconds left Governor you
have the first closing statement thank
you Rick and thank you all for tuning in
this election is a choice about our
future and I will always welcome honest
dialogue I think what you heard from my
opponent tonight is divisive rhetoric to
pit us against each other for her own
political gain I don't have time for
that I don't think you do either these
are serious times that require leaders
who can solve problems and work together
to make your life a little bit better
right now I want to continue to move our
state forward to make Michigan a place
that can attract young talent and keep
them here to make sure that women have
the right to make their own decisions
about their bodies and their health to
ensure that Michigan is a place where
every person is respected and protected
under the law and so Michigan I want for
my children and for years we cannot
trust our future to dangerous people who
peddle conspiracy theories to people for
whom problems are more politically
valuable than Solutions so people who
think they only win if someone else is
losing
we don't have time for that this is a
great state and our future is right now
work hard every single day to make sure
of it I'm asking for your vote in this
critical election thank you and good
night
Mr Dixon you have the final word the
governor would like to forget you to
forget how hard the last four years have
been with Gretchen Whitmer she's shown
us who she is she stood on this very
stage and said she wouldn't raise taxes
and she tried and tried and tried again
to raise your taxes over and over she
also said that she cares about women but
she would gladly put little boys in your
daughter's locker room she also said she
cares about parents but she hasn't stood
for parents who have said why do we have
adults Whispering sex and gender into
the ears of our little kids
this Governor's date policies are
radical dangerous and destructive
crime is up jobs are down schools are
worse and the roads didn't get fixed
that's what happens when you hire a
radical career politician you go in the
wrong direction Lansing needs Common
Sense what a horrible person this this
woman is clean our businesses and we
help them to create jobs we help them to
increase salaries and we help them to be
prosperous we need to tell our parents
we've got your back we want you to have
the final decision on what's happening
in your child's education and we need to
make sure that cops we hire more cops
and they know we have their back and
we're going to get out of their way and
let them do their job but most of all I
want to make sure that we put money back
into the pockets of our middle class
families
we need common sense and when you lack
it that's all you can see
I hope to earn your vote and bring
Michigan back to a family friendly
Michigan on November 8th I didn't really
say anything supporting voting for her
she just attacked Whitmer personal
privilege because in election years one
of the most difficult things to do is to
bring the candidates together for
debates for a lot of reasons and it's
not because candidates don't want to
debate but it's a huge investment of
time and there are a number of
considerations that you have to take for
your own candidacy for reasons on both
of your sides it might have been easier
not to do this tonight I get that so I
appreciate the fact that you personally
agree but moreover in working with your
campaigns that you were willing to
compromise and or set aside some of the
problems that we might have had in
putting this together so my personal
thanks to you and your campaigns I want
to congratulate you both on having great
folks in your campaigns to work with I
want to thank our partners all around
the state one of the important things
about doing a debate on as you may have
noticed for the past hour there have
been no commercials this isn't about
profit this is about information we feel
it's vitally important but it's even
more important to have the cooperation
of those Partners all over this all
right so doing sponsors thank you to S
Prez for 37 gifted subscriptions getting
us right to 100. this debate was
interesting in that
there was very little that would even
potentially move the polling many of you
in the audience were saying the
polling's not going to move at this
point it's you know we got three and a
half weeks uh I don't believe the
polling will move one thing I do want to
mention Whitmer is obviously the better
candidate obviously the better candidate
Whitmer is obviously the better
candidate Whitmer is obviously the
better candidate I hope I'm being clear
but I do believe I was right when a
caller asked me for my one word sort of
what comes to mind what one word comes
to mind when I hear the name Gretchen
Whitmer I said milk toast and two peep
two people wrote to me and said that
that's crazy she's relatively milk toast
and I don't say it as a pejorative
necessarily I just say she's not an
exciting candidate
um she has a better grasp of the issues
she doesn't have insane positions on
many things last thing
Whitmer is the better candidate no last
thing
um
much like Blake Masters did in his
debate with Mark Kelly
much like Greg Abbott did to some degree
in his debate with Beto
Tudor Dixon is doing what many of these
magats are doing which is they're
pretending to be way less radical during
the debates and meanwhile you look at
their Twitters and it's just cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs insanity and
um you know make of that what you will
presented without comment all right if
tomorrow night Herschel Walker shows up
to the debate with Rafael Warnock
we don't know whether he's going to show
up it's just not clear I will be live
with that debate I hope that indeed it
happens I appreciate everybody who
joined me here and we will be back very
soon make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube it's free make sure you follow
it on Twitch it's free make sure you've
liked on Facebook it's free you'll just
be notified when we do more streams see
everybody very soon probably tomorrow
Obama
[Music]